good morning John ten years ago today I
know exactly where I was because I was
inside a target for fifteen hours ten
years ago last ten years has been really
big it's been bad I can't really talk
like get my mind around it even but I do
know that I have changed a lot and what
we do on this channel has changed a lot
for example in order to prepare for this
video I went to look at my schedule for
2010 and discovered that I didn't have a
schedule in 2010 I think more
importantly than that over the last 10
years John you and I have just gotten
less interested in optimizing this
channel for growth for like reaching new
audience if you find your way here
absolutely good work but we're not
really trying to grow it for three
reasons one it's just gotten harder and
our skills are less suited to it -
YouTube recommends stuff based on lots
of different things specifically it
would like us to make eight to twelve
minute long vlogbrothers videos and I
just don't what - I like this I like
making four minute videos and that's the
rule but most importantly number three
growth beyond a certain point just gets
less interesting and worse depending on
what you want to do of course but like
specifically for this channel let's talk
about why but first how many nails does
a carpenter nee it depends on what
they're building right so you have to
look and say what do I want to do and
obviously for any given project it's bad
to have not enough nails but after a
certain point like you could have too
many nails eventually you have somebody
nails that the nails don't provide you
relief from stress they add to your
stress the point is to get to here
eventually you just spend more time
thinking about your nails than you do
actually building a house I thought
about this a lot in that last couple
weeks I just don't think that at its
core vlogbrothers is about entertainment
yes I want to do that sometimes I think
it's about doing things together and
thinking about things together
things like life's library and the
project for awesome and I work with
partners and health and just all of the
ideas that we've talked about over the
years that have helped me understand how
to be a person and how the world work
and dear Hank and John and scishow and
crash course like scishow and crash
course long ago eclipsed vlogbrothers in
subscribers and views all that stuff
that vlogbrothers just by virtue of the
fact that those channels wouldn't exist
without it has had more impact on the
world despite having a smaller
audience sometime in the last ten years
and not all at once and not at the same
time John and I realized that you don't
need a million nails to build a house we
actually internalized this it took a
while that this channel isn't about
having the biggest number under the
video it's about doing things creating
stuff thinking about things together not
only is that like a goal of mine it's
also when I'm most happy and there are
limits to that because I want it to
actually be a group of people who
recognize the humanity of all of the
other people and as the numbers get too
big you lose track of that also this
channel is unquestionably personality
based and having too many people have
opinions about your personality it turns
out is not great actually crash course
now has over 10 million subscribers and
it should grow as much as it can because
its goal is to reach people with
educational content but vlogbrothers
like know we're good you watching this
video are part of something that helps
stuff exists in the world and that stuff
is sometimes real stuff sometimes it's
ideas that we wouldn't have if we
weren't thinking together as a community
that's pretty weird and it's cool and
it's special I'm really really happy
about it and in that vein three things
first the nerdfighteria census is out
you can go fill it out right now thank
you so much to people who do that so
that we can understand who we all are
better we've been doing the census every
year since 2013 and it's super vital to
how we make decisions about what we do
if you can take the 10 to 20 minutes it
will take to fill it out please please
please do so
number two the kindle ebook of an
absolutely remarkable thing is three
bucks right now so if you want to get it
dirt cheap you can I don't think it's
gonna be that way for much longer and
finally if you want to come see us in
Atlanta or Raleigh or st. Pete next week
we will be there John I'll see you on
Tuesday